gucken Sie warum W noovia im Moment
60.000 Wohnungen stoniert die verkaufen
im Moment gerade Wohnungsbestände damit
sie Kapital reinkriegen um sich wiederum
am Markt finanzieren zu können weil sie
als aktienag notiert sind weil sie auch
Renditen erwirtschaften müssen für ihre
Anteilseigener das ist etwas was
Genossenschaften oder andere so nicht
müssen wenn wir sie mit bezahlbarem
Baugrund beispielsweise ausstatten und
mit guten Förderlinien also die Frage
ist wer soll jetzt bauen und wir
zumindest in der SPD sind nicht dafür
gewählt worden jetzt einfach all die
900.000 Wohnungen die wir im
genehmigungsüberhang in Deutschland
haben wo ganz viele dabei sind die von
Projektentwicklern mit dollen
Renditeerwartung geplant worden sind um
die jetzt alle zuzuschmeißen mit
Fördergeld damit die ihre irsinnigen
Renditeerwartung mit unserer Förderung
möglich
machen